en el vídeo anterior vimos que el
trabajo principal de un rey tracer es
determinar de qué color pintar cada
pixel
y lo hace lanzando un rayo matemático
que inicia en la cámara pasa a través de
un píxel y luego se dirige hacia la
escena
luego el rey tracer debe calcular el
punto de intersección más cercano entre
el rayo y la geometría de la escena y
entregar el color de esa geometría en
este vídeo examinaremos cómo podemos
determinar la cantidad de luz que viaja
por el rayo de regreso hacia la cámara
eso es lo que tenemos que averiguar para
determinar el color de cada pixel
esta es una pregunta bastante profunda y
compleja que se rige matemáticamente por
la ecuación de renderizado sé que
infunde algo de miedo créeme esta
ecuación aún me da pesadillas pero en
realidad es fácil de entender si las
escuchamos un poco
la cantidad de luz que viaja desde un
punto sobre una superficie de regreso a
la cámara depende de tres cosas
una que cantidad de luz cae sobre ese
punto
2 como refleja la luz la superficie del
objeto en ese punto
y 3 dónde está la cámara
examinemos cada uno de estos factores
con algo de utilería
mi escena consta de una pelota de tenis
y una fuente de luz ahora bien el primer
factor es qué cantidad de luz cae sobre
un lugar específico en esa pelota de
tenis es bastante obvio que entre más
lejos está la luz menor es la intensidad
de la luz que cae sobre la pelota por lo
tanto necesitamos saber la distancia a
la fuente de luz y necesitamos saber
también lo brillante de la luz es menos
obvio que a la hora de determinar la
cantidad de luz que cae sobre el punto
necesitamos tener en cuenta la
orientación de la superficie los ángulos
rasantes reciben menos luz o energía de
modo que parecen menos brillantes por el
contrario el punto será más brillante o
más caliente si la superficie está
orientada perpendicularmente a la
dirección de la luz
tú mismo sientes eso cada día soleado es
por eso que hace más calor al mediodía y
más frío en la mañana y en la tarde si
hay más de una fuente de luz repetimos
el proceso para cada una de ellas el
segundo factor es como refleja la luz la
superficie
el color de un objeto es una gran parte
de como éste responde a la luz pero no
es el único factor
algunos objetos tienen una apariencia
mate o difusa como la pelota de tenis
otros son brillantes y muestran reflejos
luminosos como esta bola de billar estos
dos objetos están recibiendo la misma
cantidad de luz pero tienen aspectos muy
diferentes
y otras superficies tienen un aspecto
entre mate y brillante como la piel la
madera o incluso el pelo
se dice que las superficies mates son
difuminadas y que las superficies
brillantes son especulares
por último el último factor es donde se
encuentra la cámara observa el centro
del 'número tres' en la bola de billar
nota que a medida que nos desplazamos de
un lado a otro la luminosidad de ese
punto cambia esto sucede aunque todo lo
demás permanezca igual lo único que
cambia es la ubicación de la cámara
echemos un vistazo a una versión virtual
de esta situación física hay tres
deslizadores que puedes controlar
intensidad de luz del proyector que es
similar a controlar la luminosidad de la
linterna un deslizador difuminado que
controla la opacidad de la superficie o
su rugosidad
y un deslizador especular que controla
el brillo
también puedes mover la luz del
proyector misma que se representa con un
punto blanco
para cada objeto de una película de
pixar hay un paquete de acabado el
paquete de acabado describe en detalle
visual todo lo relacionado con una
superficie incluirá fotografías del
aspecto de las cosas en la vida real
dibujos que describen por ejemplo la
apariencia de la rugosidad de una
superficie o cómo debe verse el cabello
de alguna persona en el siguiente
ejercicio podrás sentarte en el asiento
de un artista y utilizar herramientas
basadas en los conceptos que acabamos de
describir tu trabajo como artista de
pixar es emparejar los distintos
elementos del arte referente diviértete